[Música]
Rusia bombardea masivamente Ucrania las
fuerzas de musculo lanzaron 81 misiles
contra kievsa
gerson entre otras ciudades el kremlin
defiende que se trató de ataques de
precisión como respuesta a la explosión
en el puente de crimea se cuentan hasta
el momento 11 muertos y decenas de
heridos civiles
nuevo día de protestas en Irán las
manifestaciones que empezaron por la
muerte de maxamnini tras ser detenida
por la policía de la moral han
desencadenado un movimiento masivo
contra el gobierno de la República
islámica Tenemos reporte desde Teherán
el coletazo del huracán Julia causó
desbordamientos de ríos y quebradas que
dejan al menos 25 muertos y más de 50
desaparecidos en las tejerías en
Venezuela el presidente Nicolás Maduro
decretó el estado de catástrofe natural
ahora convertida en depresión tropical
Julia llegó a Guatemala tras devastar
otros países de Centroamérica
Buenas tardes Bienvenidos a las noticias
de Frank 24 en español Soy Rosa Pérez
mateu y es para mí un gusto acompañarles
empezamos esta edición con información
relacionada con la guerra en Ucrania
Rusia escaló su ofensiva sobre Ucrania
en horas de la mañana de Europa las
fuerzas de Moscú bombardearon
masivamente el territorio ucraniano de
norte a sur y de este a oeste el
ejército ruso disparó 81 misiles sobre
kiev
saporiya gerson y miko Life entre otras
ciudades el kremlin defendió que los
bombardeos son una respuesta a la
explosión en el puente de crimea de este
sábado incidente del que Moscú acusa a
kiev Putin habló de ataques de precisión
sin embargo se cuentan al menos 11
muertos y decenas de heridos de hecho el
presidente ucraniano fue lo dimmerselli
acusó a Rusia de actos de genocidio
Gabriel colchen con los detalles
la retaliación rusa fue masiva la mayor
oleada de ataques aéreos contra lugares
alejados de de batalla Desde los
primeros días de la guerra bombardeos
que llegan tras el atentado contra el
puente de crimea del que Vladimir Putin
acusado Ucrania denunciando actos
terroristas
en la mañana de hoy tal como sugirió el
Ministerio de defensa y de acuerdo con
el plan elaborado por el Estado Mayor
ruso se lanzó un ataque masivo con armas
de largo alcance y alta precisión desde
el aire el mar y la tierra contra la
infraestructura energética te mando
militar y de comunicaciones de Ucrania
desde el inicio de la guerra Rusia niega
a atacar civiles sin embargo la
evidencia demuestra lo contrario se
departaron varios muertos en la capital
kiev donde los misiles alcanzaron el
centro de la ciudad como el patio de
recreo de este parque
esta mañana han muerto cinco personas 42
están hospitalizadas
algunas en estado crítico por lo que la
cifra de Muertos podría aumentar
los misiles alcanzaron viviendas así
como una universidad
detrás de mí se puede ver uno de los
edificios de la Universidad Nacional de
construcción naval que fue alcanzado por
un misil una vez más Y de nuevo fue un
misil s-300
se registraron explosiones en varias
otras ciudades como Live saprilla harkiv
ovnipro en esta última al menos cuatro
muertos según las autoridades regionales
los ataques rusos cayeron cerca a un bus
y afectaron zonas residenciales no hay
objetivos militares aquí no esperábamos
ataques aquí es aterrador la embestida
rusa sí perjudicó la red eléctrica
ucraniana obligando al gobierno a
pedirle a los ciudadanos a reducir el
consumo de energía entre las 5 de la
tarde y las 10 de la noche y a detener
las exportaciones de energía al resto de
Europa elevando las preocupaciones
locales sobre los posibles cortes
eléctricos de cara el gobierno y
precisamente la comunidad internacional
condenó enseguida los nuevos ataques
rusos contra Ucrania el secretario
general de la otan jeansenberg calificó
los bombardeos de horribles e
indiscriminados la comisión europea
habló de crímenes de guerra y el
presidente de Estados Unidos Joe biden
dijo que son una muestra de la
brutalidad de Putin Marta Moya con las
reacciones Internacionales
La frágil sensación de normalidad en
múltiples ciudades ucranianas lejos de
los frentes de batalla terminó
repentinamente las condenas a los
últimos ataques contra la
infraestructura civil se han sucedido en
la Esfera europea una vez más Rusia ha
mostrado al mundo lo que representa es
el terror y la brutalidad la Unión
Europea dice que el ataque
indiscriminado a civiles equivale a un
crimen de guerra y algunos estados
miembros como Estonia y lituania
reiteran que no es el momento de dar
marcha atrás ante Rusia
cada vez que alguien piensa tenemos que
ayudar a Putin para salvarle la cara y
darle algo para que no haga una
estupidez eso solo le anima a seguir
avanzando porque se toma Este
apaciguamiento como un signo de
debilidad
lo que tenemos que hacer es proporcionar
defensa aérea desde al lado Aliado para
que los ucranianos puedan proteger sus
ciudades porque Rusia está
definitivamente escalando para dañar a
los civiles
el presidente francés Emmanuel maccón
reafirmó el apoyo militar al gobierno
ucraniano y expresó su preocupación
los ataques deliberados de Rusia en todo
el territorio ucraniano y contra la
población civil es un cambio profundo en
la naturaleza de esta guerra el
presidente de Ucrania también mantuvo
conversaciones con el canciller alemán y
pidió una respuesta unida y dura se ha
programado una reunión virtual de
emergencia del g7 para el martes en la
que intervendrá bolodimirselenski
y continuamos con información de la
guerra en Ucrania porque en la sede de
Naciones Unidas en Nueva York empezó la
sesión especial de la asamblea general
en que se debatirá la anexión de las
regiones de doness gerson a Rusia
recordemos que los territorios fueron
integrados a la federación rusa la
semana pasada tras la aprobación en la
cámara de diputados y en el senado ruso
una aprobación basada en los resultados
de referendos no reconocidos por la
comunidad internacional de hecho una
alianza occidental ha presentado ante la
asamblea de la ONU una moción redactada
por la Unión Europea que condena el
proceso de anexión la votación sobre el
texto se espera entre mañana y el
miércoles y será pública y no secreta
como pedía Rusia y revelará los apoyos
con los que cuenta Moscú a estas alturas
de la guerra
cambiamos ahora de información porque
hoy ha sido un nuevo día de protestas
miran recordemos que las manifestaciones
empezaron el 17 de septiembre el día del
funeral de maxa la joven de 22 años que
murió tras ser detenida por la policía
de la moral sin embargo las protestas
que empezaron por la muerte de la joven
han desatado un movimiento masivo contra
el régimen de la República islámica
incapaz por ahora de encontrar una
salida dialogada la situación nuestra
corresponsal entera en Catalina Gómez
Ángel nos amplía
en la medida que pasan los días crece la
ansiedad dentro del sistema de la
república islámica Y son más las voces
que piden porque se acaben por fin esas
protestas que ya entran en la cuarta
semana de hecho hay algunas voces
incluida el jefe de la justicia que ha
tratado de crear lazos con un sector de
la población ese que llaman ellos que no
crean los disturbios en la calle para
crear un lazos de comunicación y no
solamente esos jóvenes que están en la
calle sino por ejemplo hoy también se
unían a estas protestas los trabajadores
de una de las refinerías más importantes
del país en el Golfo Pérsico donde
cantaban eslogan es también en contra de
los líderes de la República islámica
especialmente el líder alija meneí y
ellos se unían también a un sector del
comercio especialmente en Teherán de
esos grandes bazares de la ciudad que
también se unieron a las protestas el
pasado sábado es así como el jefe de la
justicia decía venga conversemos todos
juntos y tienen problemas con la
República islámica si tienen preguntas
hagá la primera vez que se tratan de
crear esos lazos de comunicación sin
éxito hasta el momento y también llegan
un momento en que tratan de hacer una
campaña para lavar la imagen de la
policía y de las fuerzas de seguridad en
el país pero esto sucede realmente
cuando siguen circulando videos de
ataques especialmente a esos jóvenes y
esto es especialmente evidente en la
ciudad de San anddash en la región del
gurdistán iraní donde las presión y la
represión es bastante grande en los
últimos días tanto allí que las
universidades y colegios están cerradas
y en otras noticias este lunes comenzó
en París el juicio por el siniestro del
vuelo de la compañía francesa Air France
que se accidentó en 2009 mientras cubría
la ruta entre Río de Janeiro y París
228 personas murieron en el accidente
por lo que la aerolínea francesa junto
con El fabricante airbus enfrentan un
proceso judicial inédito en Francia bajo
la acusación de homicidio involuntario
ambas firmas se declaran inocentes nos
lo explica a Juan pupiales
una justicia que llega a 13 años tarde
era la Consigna de este hombre padre de
una de las 228 fallecidas del vuelo
af447
perdimos a nuestra hija y su prometido
ambos de 29 años
un gran sufrimiento por parte de ambas
familias pero el tiempo cura la herida
sin embargo todavía sentimos que aún no
se ha hecho justicia
para los familiares de las víctimas allá
Es un logro haber llegado hasta esa
instancia Y es que hubo que revertir una
decisión judicial de 2019 para abrir
este proceso contra Air France y airbus
dos firmas insignias de Francia las
cajas negras y evidenciaron que los
pilotos reaccionaron de manera
equivocada a un problema relacionado con
los sistemas antihielo en las salas y
que provocó una situación de bloqueo de
la aeronave el resultado una caída libre
contra el Océano Atlántico en medio de
una tormenta el francés asegura que una
serie de alarmas confusas abrumaron a
los pilotos herbas dice que fue un error
de los pilotos muchos interrogantes en
torno a un equipo que sumaba más de
20.000 horas de vuelo juntos este lunes
ambas empresas reiteraron su inocencia
vine hoy a expresar el nombre de Air
France nuestra más profunda compasión
con los familiares de las víctimas
dije lo que tenía que decir intenté ser
tan sincero como fue posible en relación
con lo que ocurrió
unos 50 ha llegados de las víctimas
hicieron parte de la apertura de este
juicio Habrá más de 470 testimonios hoy
uno a uno se leyeron los nombres de los
228 fallecidos se espera que el juicio
se extienda por nueve semanas y cada
compañía se enfrenta a una multa de
225.000 euros el equivalente a lo que
Air France ganaba en cinco minutos en
tiempos pruebandémicos o lo que hervás
sumaba en ganancias en dos minutos
en el congreso anual del partido
Nacional escocés la ministra principal
de Escocia Nicola extensión insistió en
realizar un segundo referendo de
Independencia en Escocia el año que
viene a la espera del fallo de la Corte
Suprema que debe decidir si acepta la
votación la mandataria señaló que los
escoceses apoyaron mayoritariamente
partidos independentistas en las
elecciones regionales del año pasado
recordemos que en 2014 Escocia rechazó
en referendo independizarse del Reino
Unido con un 55% en contra de la
separación sin embargo Esther John
aseguró que el brexit hizo cambiar a los
escoceses de opinión escuchemos
Pero Westminster no tienes respeto eso
significa que este problema siempre
estuvo destinado a terminar en los
tribunales tarde o temprano mejor
temprano a mi modo de ver
si el tribunal decide como Esperamos que
lo haga el 19 de octubre del próximo año
habrá un referéndum de independencia
vamos ahora con noticias de nuestra
región la depresión tropical Julia llegó
a Guatemala donde deja más de 150.000
afectados después de causar al menos
tres muertes en Honduras y de haber
devastado parte de Nicaragua además el
coletazo de este fenómeno en Venezuela
causó al menos 25 muertos y 52
desaparecidos como consecuencia del
desbordamiento de ríos y quebradas la
vicepresidenta de Venezuela delsy
Rodríguez informó que el sábado por la
noche cayó tanta lluvia como la que se
puede precipitar en todo un mes el agua
arrastró troncos y escombros sobre la
comunidad de tejerías en el estado de
aragua a unos 70 kilómetros de la
capital Caracas los daños materiales
afectaron negocios viviendas tierras de
cultivo y bombas de agua potable
Naciones Unidas anunció que se coordina
con las autoridades de Caracas para
prestar asistencia al país
les puedo decir que el secretario
general está profundamente entristecido
al enterarse de los devastadores
derrumbes ocurridos en las tejerías en
Venezuela extiende sus más sinceras
condolencias al pueblo y el gobierno de
Venezuela particularmente aquellos que
han perdido familiares hogares y medios
de subsistencia nuestro equipo de países
está coordinando actualmente con las
autoridades nacionales para ver cómo
podemos ayudarlos mejor en este momento
terrible
Muchísimas gracias por su atención sigan
con nosotros en Francia 24 y Francis
24.com enseguida volvemos
[Música]